we are getting straight to breaking news
tonight after
two children were found dead in a
henderson home madison kimbrough
is on scene near the 95 and sunset with
more on what she has been able to learn
madison
yeah henderson police and fire arrived
around 6 30 this evening now we were
told to leave the property but we did
get footage of the active scene before
we left
as you can see you can take a look here
this happened on calamus palm place at
the willows gated community
near 95 and west sunset the identity of
the two children have not been released
yet but we can confirm
that the deaths appear to be suspicious
in nature
we have no further details as to what
that might entail
residents in the neighborhood say they
didn't hear anything but saw an
influx of police cars entered the
neighborhood all at once earlier tonight
not too long after according to
neighbors a man was seen on the ground
undetained kneeling with his head down
we are still awaiting details from
henderson police but make sure to check
8newsnow.com
for the latest details reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now